pourquoi avons-nous les extrémités du
corps froid sur la température
extérieure baisse nos extrémité c'est à
dire nos mains et nos pieds mais aussi
nos oreilles le bout de notre nez voir
nos lèvres se refroidisse ce n'est pas
une sensation agréable mais elle est
nécessaire en effet soumis à un froid
intense notre corps cherche à protéger
en priorité nos organes internes vitaux
comme le coeur ou le cerveau c'est la
circulation du sang qui les maintient à
la bonne température et c'est donc vers
eux que le sang doit être avant tout
diriger leurs extrémités ne sont pas
prioritaires donc quand les températures
dégringolent
les tout petits vaisseaux qui permettent
au sang de circuler dans nos douanes aux
orteils no look d'oreilles ce tract le
sang circule moins dans ces zones et se
dirige vers les organes importants